uh you mentioned Kerbal Space Program
the video game uh someone asked you what
video game you recommend for learning
about space and Rockets and you said
duh Kerbal Space Program so tell me
about this game what is this game and I
also saw heard that a second one is
coming out so what what what
like uh you know I've been playing more
games recently uh because games are fun
and they remind you that life is awesome
uh so why should I play this game if you
want to learn about Rockets how to fly
how to build how to get into orbit how
to get to other planets there's no
better way to learn about Rockets this
whole language what does it entail like
do you actually like uh it's like
SimCity and Microsoft flight simulator
for Rockets oh interesting so you'll get
to like what do you design the Rockets
yeah
yeah it's okay so I started playing it
in like 2014 I think around as I'm like
falling in love with space and I became
obsessed with this game like literally
you you know you you you take a like you
get a little Command Module click you
click on a fuel tank Boop you choose
your engine Boop you choose a stage
connector Boop you connect more tanks
and build these
space planes and Fantastical things and
it's all like physics based and it's
available this sounds like a commercial
it's available on PC I'm so hacking and
console like it's it's available
everywhere but wait there's more but
wait there's more and you you uh you
said like you streamed yourself playing
this at those any of those videos up oh
yeah yeah there's some of my actually
the first videos I ever uploaded to
YouTube were re like recaptured streams
from twitch that are just physically
uploaded to YouTube this is awesome and
so it's it's me playing Chrome we I used
to do this kind of like a podcast style
thing uh I should get back into this
because it's one of my favorite things I
ever did it's called we called it
today's in space fight history but these
days I'd probably just
play Kerbal but I had my friend come sit
next to me his name's Jacob and he is a
former professional pole vaulter just
this really knows nothing about Rockets
yes knows nothing about space hilarious
like in the sweetest most fun way you
know like he you know as an adult asked
me which is bigger the Earth or the Moon
and I love that for him you know that's
that's fantastic he's just a delightful
human he would sit next to me we would
recreate a historical space flight
mission in Kerbal Space Program and he
would just sit there and play guitar and
sing about what I'm like doing and
asking questions yeah and it's still one
of my favorite things I've ever done
yeah you should definitely do something
like that so basically just uh yeah
shoot the [__] with a friend get their
curiosity going let them just sit there
and ask questions it was awesome like I
mean yeah those are some I I've done it
a handful of times I think we probably
did like 20 or 30 episodes or something
and it is it's definitely something I
would like to get back to doing can you
in the in the game like go to go to the
Moon Yeah so it's technically a
different solar system it's the Kerbal
system and you're on the planet curbin
so there's the mun m-u-n there's a
second moon in the system uh on this
planet uh it's called Min Miss they
didn't want to pay licensing fees or
what well it's just a little easier it's
a little bit smaller so the physics are
easier oh so it tries to be consistent
with physics yeah oh yeah yeah the
physics are all are all like real world
physics and I mean there's Aero
simulations there's all of it's like one
to one you know for Earth physics
awesome it's just on an easier scale
solar system so it's easier to to
navigate but there's still like there's
a planet called Eve that's kind of like
Venus so it has a really thick
atmosphere really thick really soupy
it's um it's and a lot more gravity so
it's just really really hard to get off
of
um it's easy relatively easy to land on
Eve but like that's kind of like the
ultimate boss in the game is like
getting off of Eve so that's one of my
favorite things to do is build these
crafts to to get to even and try to
return home